[Musique]
des masques jeté au sol
encadré dans les rues de paris et
diffusées sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est l'oeuvre d'un street artistes
nommés too late et l'homme originaire de
nice n'est pas tendre avec ceux et
celles qui jette ainsi leur masque par
terre au total une cinquantaine de
tableaux sont à découvrir dans la
capitale et ce jusqu'au 1er décembre
samedi un individu dépourvu de masques
circulant sur une trottinette électrique
a tenté de se soustraire au contrôle des
effectifs de police
et bien en prenant la fuite il a fini
par rapidement tombé en panne en panne
de batterie sont centraux qui est
rattrapé et interpellé et verbaliser
immédiatement pour les gendarmes du psig
derniers détails à régler
il est d'ordre vestimentaire que nous
avaler mais parce que c'est un peu son
petit jean fabrice et c'est bling bling
parce qu'il ya des paillettes que je
vais tuer les fuyards étaient une
colline et tee shirt les cheveux je suis
colère là vous m'avez colère habiller
des délinquants des situations peu
fréquente pour ses équipes
d'intervention
l'ailier droit a fait soirée oui mais
faut les faucons des portes et n'importe
quoi ni paillette et les filles arrêtez
vous mettiez cela je suis en train de me
coller la crise sanitaire ducobu de 19 a
révélé la vulnérabilité psychique de
nombreux français on observe ainsi une
augmentation importante des états
dépressifs
le nombre de personnes concernées a en
effet doublé entre fin septembre et
début novembre pour faire le comique
c'est une heure et demie ont pu passer
alors il a bossé 1h30 allez vas-y alors
au 10 mai dans les lycées qui le spina
ton ferme le communiqué du team paris
vls que pour vous cette étude est à
jeter ou est ce que cette étude prouve
que vous avez tort cette étude prouve
que vous ne savez pas lire le s pays
elle le fait le sien je suis donc plus
d'un million et demi et les lieux a reçu
à 12h30 des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
cent mille euros le gibier
j'en fais pas de saluer les sorties on
est tranquille mon écran qui s'est
terminée au nord vous avez passé une
mauvaise journée
bah ça tombe bien ça aurait pu être pire
vous pourriez être ce député qui sait ni
les salons coiffure sont fermés c'est
pas grave moi ces jeunes tombeuse elle
est grand temps qu'ils rouvrent
quand on voit dans le nord dans la
région nord par exemple qu'elle soit
beaucoup beaucoup à toucher que cette
partie de la région rhône alpes qui est
alors l est est particulièrement touché
l écouter la réponse est je ne sais pas
donc je vais vous répondre par une
pirouette que comprendront les fans de
séries télévision ce sont les mystères
de l'ouest
est ce que vous ferez vacciner contre le
coc u19 sait écouter la question se pose
pas pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
vaccination contre locaux vides 19 on
verra bien si c'est un vaccin qui est
sur mon dieu pourquoi pas si vous voulez
mais pour l'instant la question se pose
pas tout ça c'est de la science fiction
et là on vous explique y'a pas moyen
d'être plus courageux et plus héroïque
que d'être paresseux donc permettez moi
de vous dire quand même david je ne sais
pas seulement une plaisanterie au moment
du bilan il faudra retenir le fait qu'en
en effet le travail vient comme on le
sait du mot torture et que quand on
travaille moins et ben on se porte mieux
vous voyez que nous travaillons
[Applaudissements]
nono son gang des couilles
attention 13% des gels hydro alcooliques
qui sont vendus sont non conformes et
dangereux c'est notre chiffre du jour là
l'air bien de la répression des fraudes
qui a mené l'enquêté qui a constaté
qu'une partie de ces produits
contiennent mois des 60 % d'alcool
nécessaire pour qu'il soit efficace et
même les pharmacies ne serait pas
épargnée
il s'appelle robot ville est
actuellement testé dans certains
magasins d'osaka au japon concrètement
il se balade dans les rayons et avec sa
caméra il est capable de détecter les
visages qui ne portent pas correctement
leurs masques il s'approche alors des
clients et leur dit bonjour désolé de
vous déranger mais veuillez porter votre
masque qui n'a pas les sceptiques alors
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce qui permet d'être heureux ça
permet de montrer qu'on sait mais plus
fort encore avec ces capteurs il arrive
à détecter la distance entre les clients
et si certains sont trop proches les uns
des autres même chose il s'approche et
leur demande de respecter les distances
sanitaires il est pour l'instant en test
ici le futur c'est de se faire engueuler
par un robot dans les payons pas
s'étonner qu'on avait un peu plus sur
amazon et grâce
[Musique]
x
reuters nancy justus liebig c'est un
allemand qui a mis au point non pas la
technique du miroir au mercure mais la
technique du miroir avec du verre est
derrière de l'argent pour donner ce
reflet justice justus von liebig
il n'a pas créé le potage en ce moment
devant
live gold on voit que tu nages avec la
boue et la boue est très bien fait
par contre j'ai un soucis lifeguard ça
s'écrit pas comme ça en temps mon ami
c'est vrai le fcl i ve
[Musique]